hello everyone this emir from audio
science review we're back to reviewing
speakers in this case a powered uh
speaker for mostly computer use but of
course you can use it in in other
applications uh it's from company called
called vanity local company in pacific
northwest in united states
the model is called the transparent one
encore
and the company loaned it to me uh i
think a year and a half ago and i've
only gotten a chance to test it now i
won't get into reasons why
anyway it's a pretty compact speaker
sitting over here and
which makes it great for putting on the
desk a lot of times i test pro monitors
professional monitors for studio use
and when i put them on the desk
on a you know even though i have large
monitors
you know i don't want a speaker that's
this wide and this big and especially if
it's this deep this one fits perfectly
on the desk so it's quite dense now like
a lot of small speakers
it has a lot going on in there it's
first of all it's quite heavy and quite
dense um
on this thing and if you look in the on
the back you can see the rich feature
set that it has not only do you have the
tone controls but you have a subwoofer
out that's actually filtered out you can
set the crossover there's usb
connectivity uh digital in and uh i
think there's that digital uh
no just digital in and optical in and
analog in which is what i use for
testing
and importantly the connection to the
slave speaker has four wires in it why
is that important if it only has two
wires means that the
crossover is is passive and uh so it's
driving the whole speaker as a unit but
when it has four wires it means that it
can drive them actively with uh
different settings and eq for uh both
the twitter and the woofer
that and that allows a more optimal uh
design
so it's quite good in that regard and
there's a remote control lots of adapter
cables and so forth comes with it so uh
quite nice from that point of view you
don't get hardly any of these features
in in professional powered monitors
and uh
and even just simple thing as a digital
input is in much higher in speakers uh
dsp which this has uh um for active
correction um is not in in in lower end
pro monitors either
so
uh just want to make sure position is
clear and that's what this cost you know
599 dollars rather than 300 bucks or
something
um the uh measurements that you're going
to see is done with a pole near field
scanner i'll do a future video on on how
this system works but essentially we're
able to extract uh measurements as if
the speaker has no room around it as we
measure it so we're 100 getting the
characteristics of the speaker rather
than the location that i measure it
which wouldn't apply to your location
i have to uh pick a reference axis and
the reference axis in the middle of the
twitter
means everything you look at the certain
measurements when it has an angle
or you know a
height it all refers to the middle of
the twitter
on this thing usually it doesn't make
that much difference but some powered
monitors the center reference axis
between the two
anyway let's get into the measurements i
was pleasantly surprised how smooth and
good the on-axis response is which is
this uh black line
and then the base extension it goes very
deep and if you want to see why it's
because that passive radiator that was
in the back
instead of a port has been tuned pretty
low down to 40 hertz or so so for a
little speaker like this to go down to
40 hertz it's just remarkable and indeed
when i listen to it has extremely
powerful uh bass response in there which
you don't expect and you don't even get
sometimes in larger
speakers than this one other nice thing
about well let me go back this is the
passive radiator basically it's a
speaker without a motor without the
engine that drives it so it goes in and
out with a compression decompression of
the air inside the cabinet
one nice thing it does is that it
doesn't easily transmit uh resonances
from inside the cabinet out because when
you have a port it's just a hole
basically and
sound that resonates up and down or left
and right or you know
depth wise in the uh cabinet can
resonate and it can come out of the port
readily and
that this having a basically sealed
enclosure uh controls those resonances
there is one here around uh close to 600
hertz but it's way under the amplitude
of of the woofer so it doesn't cause
much of any disturbance and it has other
resonances but they're dropping off even
more and more which is quite nice
not much else to look at is basically
good design here but let's go back to
our
spin graph and we see one issue which is
down here uh notice how this curve goes
up and then it slopes down same with the
power
di
it goes up and comes down what is
happening well
as the frequencies go up the woofer
starts to shrink its directivity and
produces narrow narrow range because
that directivity is a function of of the
wavelength of sound and the size of the
drive and drivers this big and as the
wavelengths get smaller relative to the
size the the beam width starts to narrow
and
but once it hints that
that wavelength to the twitter twitter
is much tinier now the wavelength is
larger than the twitter and so the beam
becomes very wide
and you get a mismatch between the two
and that's exactly what's happening in
here
at 2000 hertz uh you know woofer's still
in charge but as it hands the uh
the
control to the twitter all sudden this
drops and drop here means that the beams
gotten wider
so the translating in english on-axis
sound is very very neutral but what hits
other surfaces in your room
loses some neutrality in this region
and on this i'll talk about it a little
bit more as we go through
so if you were to use this in a home
setup as opposed to on the desk
we have a set of statistical uh models
that tell us which reflections in the
room are the strongest and if we sum
them all with this speaker we get this
green line and you can see the green
line now has a pronounced dip over here
and that happens because the directivity
error so we basically have less energy
around two kilohertz 2.5 kilohertz than
we do on axis so if you
if you heard both the on and off axis
mixed up
the net result would be this guy the
predicted in-room response which will
have a dip in here but again this
research was done for speakers in a room
not in a situation where you put a
speaker on your desk so it doesn't 100
apply
but go and put it anyway you do still
have the ceiling and the floor bounds
for example and the ceiling bounces is
this red one you can see that it's got
the deepest
reduction of of power here so
you can put an absorber on the ceiling
where the first reflection is from the
speaker going up and hitting you
excuse me and that may help um the floor
one also may help a little bit but in
this case would be your desk so i don't
know how you deal with that but a little
bit of absorption on the ceiling may be
all right um and also having it be high
works the same way also relative to the
on axis if the ceiling is high then it
loses energy and becomes basically like
having an absorber there
okay
i was pleasantly surprised with power
handling at the 86 db spl it essentially
clears my threshold that i set over here
and you can see in here there's hardly
anything to worry about at 96 db spl
still doesn't fall apart but clearly the
woofer gets unhappy which is very very
common in smaller speakers they just
can't handle that much power
going through it
now if we look at the beam width
in a horizontal
axis and
look at it at different frequencies with
the same amplitude we can see that the
beam width sort of starts over here
becomes flat which is what we like to
see then all of a sudden the beam width
widens and then it continues to go to
get narrow and this is the twitter
response and this is the woofer response
and this is the mismatch that i was
talking about in here and so
you know the
if you move your head you know a little
bit past this 60 degrees what you hear
in these frequencies is not the same as
what you hear in these other frequencies
so a little bit of tonality variation
there
um this same graph can be
produced as a heat map and and that's
what you're seeing here so this has the
same information as that vertically uh
the two two-way systems are always a
message restrictivity fortunately the
effect is not as pronounced as for as
our perception um but regardless and you
don't move around as much with your
height as you do left and right so
uh with respect to that do what as i did
in my listening test which is make sure
the twitter is either at your ear height
or is pointing it up so that you're
within this sweet spot which is plus or
minus 10 degrees or 20 degrees in here
uh don't go sitting too far out like if
you have 50 degrees
the speaker's way down or way high
then you also have this hole to worry
about where the response drops way off
um
if you're looking at our cst waterfall
we see a few resonances and that's
typical uh
just by every speaker i measure i've
never measured the speaker it doesn't
have resonances and there's some in here
we have our impulse response and step
response and you can see about
six and a half millisecond latency in
here and that's because of the dsp
processor the processing that it's using
that shouldn't be noticeable in most
applications
but
you know if you gamer maybe maybe that
matters to you uh i don't know i'm not a
gamer
but
anyway just be mindful that there's a
price to be paid for the signal
processing that optimizes that on axis
to be nice and flat
um for listening tests i uh put the
speaker on my desk on each side of my
monitor which unfortunately you can't
see but i've got about a six foot wide
desk and i've always put the speaker in
the same spot play the same clips and in
that first location it sounded uh
quite good as far as the bass i mean
just surprising amount of bass it has uh
i could literally feel the floor shaking
under me which you know little speaker
like this shouldn't be able to do
but it was able and that was quite nice
and and quite pleasant the tonality was
very good but i wondered if i'm hearing
that
dip if i go back to predicted
response you know i was wondering
whether i am hearing a ditch in here so
i actually put in an eq and try to pull
that up and
i thought it and then also took out some
of this bass hump over here when i did
both of those the sound became
more open
and the bass became tighter
but i got to tell you that that deep
bass was seductive and this may be too
bright for some people but certainly if
you have equalization which you should
uh it's worth putting a gentle filter in
here around two kilohertz and uh knock
down this thing i only knocked this down
by one or two db this bass amp
and this one i think i raised it by 3 db
um and on some music like female vocals
this was nice that combination was nice
but other things i had heavy bass like i
said you know i prefer the warmer sound
that it gave me than when i did this not
that it made it bright but it it sort of
changed the character uh this area by
the way is always synonymous for with
openness so the sound sort of collapses
when you have less energy there and
opens up when you have more there uh on
this thing
okay
um so that was that so i didn't develop
i developed an eq but i'm not posting it
for that reason if i can't convince
myself that the effect is positive then
you know i'm not going to present it and
try to defend it um and then i started
to listen to my long playlist of
reference tracks and and just the music
was very enjoyable very clean um i
should say that if you crank it up way
way way high gradually
the uh
ticking sound starts to appear which is
telltale sound of the amplifier
running out of power and then the bass
becomes less clean
there never was a case where all sudden
i hear a pop which i don't like or
anything bottoming out uh it just was a
smooth
a little bit of compression and then you
would start to hear the distortions and
that was playing very loud and playing
just one speaker if you're playing both
probably uh does better and for desk
application you wouldn't need more power
anyway and this is a classic thing with
powered speakers especially in smaller
sizes
in my experience they almost always run
out of amplification power so passive
speakers aren't as good design wise as
the active ones but you can juice them
up with very powerful amplifiers
so that's the trade-off you get until
you get to multi-thousand dollar powered
speakers that become very heavy very
large then they have very powerful
you know hundreds of watts of
application power and then you know you
don't bottom them out
all right so overall clearly design good
design and engineering has gone in there
to achieve that flat base to design that
passive radiator in the back to manage
the resonances in the cabinet
lots and lots of connectivity the one
thing is just there's a bit of
directivity error and
it makes for a good test case of how
important is directivity
the first on-axis response is the most
important thing and here latches on to
that as as the signature and the
tonality and getting that right is the
high order bit then the priority after
that is the indirect feel indirect sound
which is a directivity and then
distortion power and all those things
sort of follow so that's the order you
want to evaluate things and this one
gets a high order bit right and then
some mistake on the directivity error
and goes on um so overall i'm going to
recommend it i like the sound i like the
form factor i like the functionality
you know we're a little bit more perfect
that would be nice but it isn't uh on
this thing but
certainly a good choice with all that
connectivity you can hook it up to a tv
quick and run the toslink optical to it
and instantly you have some
far better than any soundbar
okay so i'm going to recommend it uh
on this thing and that's all i have for
you see you in a future video bye